pues aquí estamos una vez más con
ustedes en nuestro espacio de cultura
para hablar de la entrega número 95 de
los premios Oscar con el repaso de los
ganadores elegidos o por la Academia y
para hablar de este tema pues quién
mejor que la periodista especializada
que es leurel lea un agradecimiento a
usted por permitirme acompañarla y pues
hablemos de lo que fue esta gala número
95 Buenos días Ángela sí ganar siete
estatuillas es lo que podemos llamar un
triunfo
todo en todas partes al mismo tiempo un
hombre que resume bien esta película
completa y extravagante que fue un éxito
tanto del lado del público como de la
crítica y esos siete premios Oscar hacen
parte además de las categorías más
importantes mejor película mejor
dirección para Los Daniels Daniel
sheiner y Daniel Juan mejor actriz mejor
actor y actriz de reparto mejor guión
original y mejor edición muchos premios
y para las personas que todavía no han
visto esta maravillosa sin tato en al
mismo tiempo es la historia de una mujer
interpretada por Michelle dueña de una
pequeña lavandería que iba mal y tiene
problemas de familia pero pronto se dará
cuenta de que lo que ocurre en su mundo
real puede tener consecuencias en
universos paralelos en lo que se llama
el multiverso ya va a empezar a pasar de
un mundo al otro y a vivir muchas
aventuras miramos el trailer
[Música]
Pues bien No nos queda ninguna duda que
todo en todas partes al mismo tiempo es
la gran ganadora de la noche pero le a
pesar de que hacía parte de las
favoritas no obedece a ese perfil que
normalmente está ocupando estos lugares
de la mejor película en los Oscar Eso es
muy cierto Ángela primero es una cinta
de ciencia ficción es una producción
independiente una excéntrica comedia con
artes marciales que están muy lejos de
las películas que normalmente ganan
premios en esta ceremonia los Oscar pero
que tenía suficiente corazón Ingenio
para volverse una obra que yo creo que
sean memorable y por eso parece ser una
buena noticia para el cine y para
Hollywood de manera general todo en
todas partes al mismo tiempo es una
generosa celebración del cine me parece
a través de la locura de la creatividad
y de la audacia y no habría sido lo
mismo si las la cinta alemana Sin
novedad en el frente hubiese ganando el
premio a mejor película es la segunda
adaptación a la pantalla de una famosa
novela antibélica alemana y cuenta el
horror de las trincheras de la Primera
Guerra Mundial la producción de Netflix
tenía nueve nominaciones
hacia parte de las favoritas algo que
podría igual entenderse por el contexto
de la guerra en Ucrania y las terribles
imágenes que que deja la invasión
de Rusia y que seguramente
afectaron también a las personas que
votaron en los premios Oscar y se fue
esta película con cuatro estatuillas de
esas podemos destacar el premio a mejor
película internacional y mejor
fotografía para el gran trabajo de James
en un trabajo muy inmersivo que nos hace
sentir parte de esas trincheras con los
soldados en la sociedad la niebla y la
sangre de esas trincheras es que nos lo
contaban en la ceremonia que fue una
producción espectacular más de 400
extras más un kilómetro de escenarios
que fueron adaptados al detalle y de una
forma digamos muy bella y muy artística
lea Pero además de esto Pues esta fue
una ceremonia podríamos decir diferente
para empezar fue una ceremonia sin
bofetadas no Y además de que recompensó
los regresos como solamente Hollywood
puede hacerlo Sí es que la verdad fue
una ceremonia muy linda
llena de discursos de agradecimiento muy
conmovedores sobre creer en sus sueños y
nunca renunciar empezando con brendan
Fraser que se fue con la estatuilla
mejor actor él llegó a la fama por sus
papeles en comillas y blockbusters como
la momia pero después de su carrera se
después su carrera se puso entre
paréntesis recordemos que en la época
del movimiento mitu anunció que había
sido agredido sexualmente a principios
de los años 2000 además aseguró que su
cuerpo estaba magullado por todas las
acrobacias que hacía en sus películas y
regresó a los focos a los 54 años con lo
que seguramente es el rol de su vida en
la ballena de dar en
obeso profesor de literatura que intenta
reconectar con su hija y brendan Freezer
de verdad ilumina esta película con su
delicadeza su presencia y su humanidad y
otra cara muy conocida de Hollywood pero
que ganó el domingo su primer Óscar es
la de Jamie se alzó con la estatuilla a
mejor actriz de reparto por su papel de
memorable Villana en todo en todas
partes al mismo tiempo Jimmy Ortiz
recibió una lluvia de aplausos cuando se
subió al escenario durante la ceremonia
y arrancó su discurso celebrando la la
fuerza del colectivo afirmó parece que
estoy aquí sola pero soy sientas de
personas antes de declarar al público
ustedes me amaron en las películas de
género como Halloween en particular
mucho tiempo películas no muy apreciadas
en los Oscar y aquí estoy hoy y encarnó
está revancha bueno en cada entrega
siempre hay una discusión abierta en
torno a la diversidad de los personajes
y también de los ganadores en esta
ocasión podríamos decir que se vio un
poco más Especialmente con esta gran
representación de los actores asiáticos
con todo en todas partes al mismo tiempo
que se puede decir de ese tema sí
podemos decir que que hubo un poquito
más de diversidad y eso se debe Es sobre
todo al excelente elenco de todo en
todas partes al mismo tiempo y a su
estrella la actriz de Malasia Michelle
Gio que ganó el prestigioso premio a
mejor actriz después de cuatro décadas
en la industria cinematográfica primera
actriz no blanca que gana este Óscar
desde alevery en 2002 y justamente hubo
un momento bastante simbólico porque fue
la misma alevery que presentó este este
premio de mejor actriz y que Y qué le
pasó Y qué le pasó a Michael en el
y micheliego primera actriz asiática en
ganar esta estatuilla eso de toda la
historia de la ceremonia pero creo que
la emoción llegó a uno de sus niveles
más altos de toda la noche cuando que
Juan También aparte del elenco de todo
en todas partes al mismo tiempo llegó al
escenario para recibir el galardón a
mejor actor de reparto la recompensa una
carrera que comenzó con los éxitos de
taquilla que seguramente conoces Ángela
los goonies en Generations y el templo
maldito pero después ante la falta de
ofertas
se dedicó a trabajar como doble y a la
coreografía está conseguir este papel y
renacer de una cierta forma de sus
cenizas un trofeo muy simbólico para
este actor nacido en Vietnam cito él
dijo mi historia empezó en un barco pasé
un año en un campo de refugiados Y de
alguna manera acabé aquí en el mayor
escenario Hollywood dicen que historias
así solo ocurren en las películas No
puedo creer que esto me está pasando a
mí no para mí Los goonies siempre en el
corazón y lea hablemos de los otros
ganadores de esta ceremonia sí Ángela
para cerrar sobre esos discursos muy
conmovedores
teníamos que destacar a la diseñadora
Ruth y Carter que se fue con su segunda
estatuilla para el vestuario de black
panther wakanda forever después de haber
ganado su primer Oscar en 2019 con la
primera película black panther Y de
nuevo un trofeo histórico por lo que se
convirtió en la primera mujer
afroamericana en ganar dos Oscar lo que
demuestra bien la falta de diversidad de
estos premios en 95 años de existencia
Wanda forever que es una película sobre
el Duelo con personajes de mujeres
negras poderosas y con un paralelo muy
claro durante la ceremonia cuando esta
misma rusa y Carter
Estas mujeres negras poderosas y dijo
que esta película La preparó a vivir su
propio duelo de su madre que que
lamentablemente falleció hace unos días
entonces un momento que marcó de manera
definitiva la ceremonia y un premio que
hace parte de los más prestigiosos el de
mejor guión adaptado se fue para ellas
hablan de la canadiense Sara Pole única
mujer directora nominada dentro de la
categoría de las mejores películas la
categoría la más conocida Ella hizo un
gran trabajo de adaptación del libro
homónimo de Miriam to sobre crímenes
reales que sucedieron en una remota
Colonia menonita en Bolivia donde siete
hombres Fueron condenados por violar a
más de 100 mujeres entre 2005 y 2009
tras cedarlas con somníferos
y decir que estaban locas no un discurso
muy familiar demasiado familiar Era la
culpa de satán o que eran sueños y pese
a todo con esta historia tan poderosa se
queda corto una vez más el premio de los
Oscar en hablar de feminidad en hablar
de feminismo más que todo y de
violencias contra las mujeres
Lamentablemente un tema que es de todos
los días para nosotras y que muestra el
lado político de los Oscar y es que el
premio a mejor documental se fue bueno
sin sorpresa Ángela a Nadal ni un
documental sobre el opositor ruso su
director Daniel roer dedicó el premio a
todos los prisioneros políticos y la y
la esposa de alexey se dirigió a él
diciendo estoy soñando con un día en que
serás libre mantente fuerte mi amor
palabras que destacaron mucho en esta
noche y de una cierta forma también la
mejor película animada que se fue para
la versión de Guillermo del Toro de
Pinocho de este cuento italiano está
enmarcada es una obra muy enmarcada en
un contexto de la Italia fachista
entonces también tiene tiene este color
muy político Bueno nos quedan solamente
dos minutos lea rápidamente estos
momentos que marcaron la ceremonia y por
favor sus recomendaciones sobre lo que
nos faltó por ver Pues dentro de los
momentos que marcaron la la ceremonia
obviamente Tenemos que hablar de las
canciones que las cinco canciones que
los artistas interpretan los que hacen
parte de esta competición
teníamos obviamente bueno el elenco
indio de la película rr para la canción
natural La que se fue con el galardón
teníamos también a Rihanna y Lady Gaga y
fueron canciones muy lindas y eso eso
marcó mucho tan al público como como
también a los actores y actrices
presentes yo creo Bueno pues la música
da vida definitivamente a las películas
Gracias a usted lea nos quedan las
recomendaciones pero la invitación es a
que nuestros televidentes pues hagan la
tarea no y se acerquen a ver tantas
películas que se fueron sin nada pero
que definitivamente valen la pena
Gracias a usted No gracias a ustedes
Bueno pues eso es todo por el momento
sigan en France 24
[Música]